cracked and damaged this home in
joshimat has become unlivable as he
surveys the damage rajendra Lal tells us
he first spotted cracks in 2021 but he
says authorities ignored him these
became wider and destroyed his home
we are living in fear we don't know what
the future holds for us we haven't eaten
properly for days the children are
missing school our daily routines have
been disrupted we are struggling and
don't know how to handle this situation
similar damage can be seen across the
small Himalayan town in northern India
roads have fishes many homes are falling
apart nearly half the town has been
affected joshimat is the gateway to
Hindu and sacred religious sites it's
also an important military base near the
Chinese border authorities are blaming
bad drainage systems and overpopulation
for sinking this land
authorities have moved hundreds of
people to temporary shelters families
are sharing one room and have brought
basic supplies the rawat family says
they spent all their savings to build
their home they're anxious about their
future
we are shivering in this cold it's tough
for the children we have to warm milk
for them it's becoming difficult to look
after them authorities are giving us
food so at least that is taken care of
but what about our future what will we
do
experts say they've been warning
authorities about the pace of
development in the area for decades they
are blaming corruption and lack of
leadership for the disaster
no government has tackled this issue
properly they didn't listen to
Scientific advice it's not just Joshua
there are several other towns which have
come up in similar locations and could
face similar disasters in the future
authorities are marking high-risk areas
and homes they're also offering eighteen
hundred dollars as compensation several
people are leaving town before the
situation gets worse many say they will
need more money from the government so
they can relocate and start rebuilding
their lives Al Jazeera yoshimat Northern
India